Another element of unfortunate reality is
that this morning, Donald Trump devolved into
a childish tweet storm appearing to potentially
even have a psychotic break of some kind,
maybe under pressure from the Corona virus
fiasco.
And once again, proving that we are at public
health risk by having this man as president
and at least nominally in charge of the Corona
virus response.
You know, if it's really Jared Kushner behind
the scenes or whoever.
It's bad no matter what.
Trump is at least nominally in charge.
Look at what the president has spent the morning
tweeting, first attacking news coverage on
MSNBC, saying, watch the first five minutes
of poorly rated morning psycho on MSA DNC
just to see if he is as nuts as people are
saying he's worse.
Such hatred and contempt.
I used to do his show all the time before
the 2016 election.
Then cut him off.
Wasn't worth the effort.
His mind is shot then.
Remember that yesterday nearly two thousand
Americans died.
Yesterday, the death toll was right around
1950.
Trump insists everything is fine and tweets,
quote, It's amazing that I became president
of the United States with such a totally corrupt
and dishonest lame stream media going after
me all day and all night.
Either I'm really good, far better than the
fake news wants to admit, or they don't have
nearly the power as once thought.
Then, as the official number of cases in the
United States will pass 800000.
Today, Trump tweets about his ratings saying,
quote, I've had great ratings my whole life.
There's nothing unusual about that for me.
The White House news conference ratings are
through the roof, Monday Night Football, bachelor
finale, New York Times.
But I don't care about that.
I care about going around the fake news to
the people.
Remember that the daily press briefings are
some of the most lie riddled public facing
events that Donald Trump has done in his presidency.
And then lastly, once again, Trump tweeting
about these phantom approval ratings among
Republicans.
We never know where they're coming from.
I think they might come from just surveys
that Donald Trump promotes through YouTube
channels saying, quote, Ninety six percent
approval rating in the Republican Party.
Thank you.
This must also mean that, most importantly,
we are doing a good, great job in the handling
of the pandemic.
Now, the truth is the opposite.
In the last Gallup presidential approval poll,
I told you about this yesterday, a Trump's
approval dropped nine points since the last
poll.
That's the fastest approval decline between
polls of Donald Trump's entire presidency.
But none of it matters.
It's all a question of what can his followers
be convinced of.
Nearly 2000 people died yesterday.
We're passing eight hundred thousand cases
today.
Testing has not actually increased for weeks.
And Trump spends the morning bragging about
ratings and attacking Mika Brzezinski and
Joe Scarborough.
MSNBC hosts This is not a president.
Maybe someday
we
will have one.